MONDAY.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME, TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT
AS YOU'VE SEEN EARLIER TODAY,
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION UNVEILED 13
SEPARATE INDICTMENTS AGAINST
RUSSIAN CITIZENS WHO OELGDLY
TRIED TO MEDDLE IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF PROPAGANDA ABOUT THOSE
INDICTMENTS AND WHAT THEY MEAN
IN COMING DAYS.
WE'VE LOOKED AT THEM CAREFULLY
AND HERE'S WHAT SEEMGS TO BE
TRUE ABOUT THEM.
THE INDICTMENTS DESCRIBE A
RUSSIAN EFFORT TO, QUOTE, SEW
DISCORD IN THE AMERICAN
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
THE EFFORT DPAN IN 2014 -- BEGAN
IN 2014 BEFORE DONALD TRUMP OR
ANY OTHER CANDIDATE DECLARED FOR
THE RACE.
THE EFFORT DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE A
SPECIFIC IDEOLOGICAL EVENT.
IT WAS TO SERVE UP TROUBLE.
THEY RAN FACEBOOK ADS AND TRIED
TO ORGANIZE EVENTS THAT
CRITICIZED HILLARY CLINTON AND
SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP.
THE RUSSIANS ALSO SUPPORTED LEFT
WINGERS LIKE BERNIE SANDERS AND
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
HILLARY CLINTON WAY THE FRONT OF
THE RUNNER FOR MOST OF THE RACE
AND SHE YANKED HER CHAIN.
STARTED ORGANIZING RALLIES
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
RALLIES PROBABLY AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
ANTI-MUSLIM EVENT ELGDLY
ORGANIZED BY THE RUSSIANS DREW
FOUR RSVPs.
AN ANTI-HILLARY EVENT IN
NEW YORK GOT 45.
SUCCESSFUL EVENT THE RUSSIANS
APPEARED TO HAVE PULLED OFF
SEEMS TO BE AN ANTI-TRUMP RALLY
IN NEW YORK CITY AFTER THE
ELECTION RIGHT OUTSIDE TRUMP
TOWER.
NOW, ALL OF THIS IS ANNOYING,
THEY'RE FOREIGNERS.
BUT NONE OF IT SEEMS MOMENTOUS.
HERE'S WHAT IS NOT IN THE
INDICTMENT.
ANY EVIDENCE AT ALL THAT ANY
RUSSIAN BEHAVIOR CHANGED A
SINGLE VOTE OR DID ANYTHING TO
SWAY THE ELECTION IN ANY
DIRECTION.
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN ADMITTED AS MUCH
TODAY.
>> THERE'S NO ALLEGATION IN THIS
INDICTMENT THAT ANY AMERICAN WAS
A KNOWING PARTICIPANT IN THIS
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN THE
INDICTMENT THAT THE CHARGE
CONDUCT ALTERED THE OUTCOME OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> Tucker: IN A STATEMENT THIS
AFTERNOON THE WHITE HOUSE EVEN
BOERNTED ABOUT TODAY'S NEWS,
QUOTE, JONLD J. TRUMP HAS BEEN
FULLY BRIEFED ON THE MATTER
DPLANLD TO SEE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S SPECIAL SKEGS FURTHER
INDICATE THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA.
CLOSE THE 20 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DIEPTED SO FAR.
STILL NOT A SINGLE PIECE OF
EVIDENCE THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDED WITH PUTIN.
COLLUSION, YOU REMEMBER, WAUPGS
THE REASON WE SUPPOSEDLY NEEDED
THIS MULTI-YEAR, MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR INVESTIGATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT HAS GROUND
WASHINGTON TO A HALT AND PUT
YOUR CONCERNS ON THE BACK
BURNER.